[Applause]
thank you max thanks guys andy how you
doing
you're very good are you getting the
holiday spirit yeah i am getting in the
holiday spirit i
but i i still the last minute shopping
is killing me you know
you know that's the problem here people
don't know i can't do any shopping
either because we're so busy working
here at the show right
that we don't have time to go out and
actually buy presents for people i know
so i was going to ask uh you know
everybody if it's okay
if tonight on the show andy and i sort
of went out for a drive and did some
quick
christmas shopping i hope that's okay
with everybody but we're really
we got no choice come on over
all right let's go oh i have a seat
right there
hey that's comfy yeah here we go i like
plywood
all right let's get out there and shop
let's see if i can get the old
old gal started up oh
i thought that was the starter i'm sorry
well the way it is
all right let's ease this baby into gear
here let's go
there we go and then slip out
i don't know there we go right up even
with the cold weather oh it's very nice
let's say goodbye
to everybody bye to the crew
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh ah
they got to build a ramp there yeah i
know all right desk access
okay here we go now andy uh i think the
best thing to do is maybe if you and i
headed to a shopping mall that's where
we could get the most shopping done
you're a genius well that's why i got
this job got some shopping to do go to a
mall all right let's take a turn there's
one around here somewhere hold on a
second let me
there we go ah that was a good special
effect
beautiful hair very nice
can you hear that andy oh that was the
most annoying holiday song i know
christmas carolers i hate him let's take
care of it
[Applause]
how's that for a sleigh ride yeah hey
anyway
there's still a couple standing let me
get them
nice hey andy that woman's gotta tickle
me elmo doll
i'll make it i gotta watch this uh hey
ma'am uh do you know what uh
time it is
out of here yeah i got an elmo
20 minutes we killed
oh man i'll get rid of him yeah all
right let's see if uh
we you know we still don't have any
presents yeah we don't have any presents
at all thing was a disaster i know it's
just like whoa
oh hey great what do we get presents
oh that'll do nicely
[Applause]
come on let's go sorry let's get out of
here
hey look it's the christmas tree oh
that's pretty
hey andy what's with that guy he looks
really sad look at him no
it's back i'm gonna try and cheer him up
all right you know i got an idea right
here
watch this okay
this is gonna make everything
that's really nice hi i have an idea
what's uh
you want to go to the skating rink to
whiskey i'd love to go to the skating
rink okay
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
oh man it's hard to drive on this stuff
oh what oh no he's got a hammer
or something okay let's get out of here
come on we're sorry
oh god we're spinning all over
i can't control it yeah santa's gonna
kill us all right i got an idea we
just we just got a commercial all right
all right we're gonna do that we're
gonna take a little break